did you or did you not decriminalize
public urination in Washington DC did
you lead the charge to do so no it the
revised criminal code left that as a
criminal charge did you
suanimous but she keeps going the charge
to decriminalize public urination in
Washington DC no ma'am did you ever vote
in favor of decriminalizing public
urination in Washington DC the revised
criminal code did you ever support kept
it as a criminal offense did you
and you support this Criminal I voted
for it yeah you voted oh God
this is going so wrong and it's
absolutely delightful to keep it as a
criminal offense that's correct
wait sir you're telling me
you never advocated to make public
urination not a crime you never voted to
make it not a crime and you voted to
keep it a crime yes hmm interesting